hey youtubers is Charlie Merry Christmas
spider-man Marvel Cinematic Universe
this is gonna be my video that'll
explain what's going on what it means
for all the dates for all the movies
that are happening in phase 3 as well as
the Sony franchise and all the stuff
that we want to see most important stuff
here's what's happening Andrew Garfield
is officially out a spider-man they're
gonna cast a new spider-man that person
will appear in Captain America Civil War
which is being released May 6th 2016 so
we might meet that actor at Comic Con
hopefully they'll cast that new actor
and those announced and during their
Avengers panel I feel like everyone's in
agreement that Miles Morales would be
the best choice for a new Spider Man
especially a new spider-man franchise
marvel's press release specifically
mentions Peter Parker anything can
change between now and then but I feel
like Sony wants to play it safe they're
gonna reboot the spider-man franchise
things change all the time Marvel push
the dates of four of their phase three
films in order to make room for this
spider-man release that spider-man movie
the first spider-man movie that Sony's
gonna release as part of the new
franchise will be July 28th 2017 that
was previously the day that Thor 3 was
supposed to come out so Marvel pushed
the dates for Thor 3 Black Panther
Captain Marvel and Inhumans all that
stuff just got pushed by a couple months
it's not a huge deal in Avengers
infinity War part 1 in part 2 none of
the dates have changed about that
there's been no mention as to whether or
not spider-man's gonna appear in those
films but I think the odds are pretty
good okay so thinking ahead what does
this actually mean what is it actually
gonna look like with spider-man in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but also in a
Sony franchise after he appears in
Captain America's Civil War he will
forever be part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so Marvel whenever they're
getting ready for like a new spider-man
Sony film Marvel will help give them a
bump like a shout out in the movie Sony
will do the same thing for the Marvel
films that spider-man is going to be a
part of when they do get ready to make
that first new spider-man film it will
be a reboot but what I'd really like to
see them do is just skip the origin
story skip the Uncle Ben's stuff and
save themselves 30 minutes of movie that
they could just spend in the action of
whatever the main story is you guys can
let me know if you agree but I feel like
this reboot is coming so soon after the
last reboot that we all know the origin
story even people who have never seen a
spider-man movie
probably understand spider-man's origin
story I don't feel like there's a need
to tell it again something else I'd also
like to see a young Spider Man I'd
really like it if spider-man were way
younger than the other Avengers in the
context of civil war I feel like it's
perfect
spider-man is taken advantage of by both
sides Captain America and Iron Man he's
pulled in both directions
he looks up to them like big brothers so
he should be much much younger than them
they're not gonna want to cast an actor
that's gonna age out of the role before
they get a chance to make three films
it's just whenever they reboot
franchises they usually can see them as
trilogies
speaking of which they have not dumped
the sinister six movie supposedly Sony
is still developing a sinister six movie
with Drew Goddard and his awesome is all
this news is it's actually bad news for
a V Arad he is mentioned nowhere in this
Marvel press release I think that
actually probably probably makes most of
the fans happy
of all the people associated with
spider-man the actors the people behind
the scenes almost no one has been
complained about more than a V Arad have
you ever wondered he is the hold up on a
Miles Morales spider-man he used to
control the character and said that
spider-man will never be anyone but
Peter Parker so if you want to get upset
about Miles Morales not being spider-man
blame a V Arad now that it sounds like
he's out and Amy Pascal is in she's
gonna be the one to co-produce the
film's with Kevin Feige and Marvel they
can still weave him into that universe
so that eventually he could become
spider-man
so his chances are dramatically rising
if you want to learn more about Captain
America Civil War it's not gonna be
exactly like it was in the comics it'll
be a little bit different although they
do have spider-man now I've already made
a whole bunch of videos about it so I'll
add some links in the description but I
think the most recent big development is
that Daniel Bruhl was pretty much
confirmed as Baron Zemo when else do we
want to see in this new spider-man
rebooted franchise
I think JK Simmons should come back as
JJ under Jameson nobody can touch that
performance he's amazing maybe like a
Flash Thompson venom
I feel like that'd be awesome and he
could also end up crossing over with the
Avengers or guardians of the galaxy at
some point he's actually in the comics
he actually did crossover with guardians
of the galaxy recently Sally Fields was
an amazing Aunt May I'd like to see her
come back Norman Osborn as Green Goblin
I don't know about Dane DeHaan Dane
DeHaan is an amazing actor but
definitely the Norman Osborn character
Mary Jane Watson I would totally love to
see her back I was kind of bummed when
shailene woodley got cut out of amazing
spider-man
she was actually supposed to be in that
movie they film scenes but just decided
the movie got too bloated and yeah I
would like to see an Avenger cameo in
that first spider-man film if Marvel and
Sony are gonna try and promote each
other's films then I feel like if
spider-man's gonna be in an Avengers
film or Captain America film that one of
those Avengers should be in the
spider-man film at least a little bit
just a brief cameo the other really big
news is that Angelina Jolie is being
courted for the Captain Marvel film just
because Marvel wants to get a strong
female director on its roster that
doesn't mean that she would be cast as
Captain Marvel I don't want to see that
happen as much as I love Angelina Jolie
I think she's a great director I think
she'll have a really interesting take on
the character I want them to cast
someone that's a little bit younger so
they can be in like six or seven Marvel
films without aging out of the role
Robert Downey jr. is like the one
exception to that Robert Downey jr. has
already said that he's gonna ride that
role into the ground so or at least he's
gonna play Tony Stark til people stop
paying to go see Marvel films which
means he's never gonna leave the other
Avengers not so much I expect at least
one of them to be recast after Avengers
infinity War part two that's not till
like May 2019 so so don't worry that's a
long way off all the actors that we have
now will pretty much be the same for the
rest of phase 3 so now I know you're all
saying so what about Fox x-men Marvel
crossovers now that's like a long long
long ways off so we don't know about
Fantastic Four x-men that's all still
gonna be completely independent from the
Marvel stuff if Joss Whedon is gonna
stop directing Marvel films I would like
to see him direct an x-men film at some
time he had an amazing run on
astonishing x-men I feel like he could
do something really amazing with the
Kitty Pryde character I'd really like to
see a Kitty Pryde x-man film just just
by herself
it's just that Joss Whedon said he wants
to direct a female superhero film most
of the best female characters that
Marvel has are controlled by other
Studios namely Fox with all the x-men
characters so if Joss Whedon's gonna
direct a female Marvel film and it's not
gonna be Captain Marvel it's probably
gonna have to be an x-man film I feel
like Fox would be totally jazzed up at
the idea of working with Joss Whedon
again I almost forgot to mention it - it
would be really awesome now that Sony
and Marvel or sharing spider-man if we
could see like spider-man stuff
happening in the TV series like Daily
Bugle stuff on daredevil
really I feel like everyone wants Logan
Lerman to be the new spider-man I'd be
totally cool with that I feel like you
can totally pull it off
it's just gonna be a minor role in
Captain America so we can get his feet
wet there get used to the character and
then they can kind of decide what do
they want to take it when they get to
the first Sony film be sure to write in
the comments who do you want to see is
this new spider-man and what do you want
them to include in the new franchise so
in related news because this is such a
big deal I'm totally gonna do a Q&A for
this at least by Thursday I'm a little
backed up with videos I have something
special that's happening later today so
I won't be able to post my flash video
till late tonight and then I'll post
Gotham after that so why you continue to
freak out about spider-man and wait for
the rest of those videos you can click
here to learn more about Avengers age of
Ultron and you can click here for my top
Ultron stories from the comics thank you
so much watching so let's all high-five
and remember you deserve the good things
that happen to you
you